All right. So, welcome as folks uh
trickle in. So, if you weren't aware,
we're going to be talking about
knowledge graph and AI. Big surprise,
right? This has not been discussed at
all at this conference in any way,
shape, or form. So, we're going to learn
a lot today. [laughter]
So, I am Ashley Faith. If you don't know
me, most people know me from my YouTube
channel. It's just my name if you want
to go check that out. Um, but I also
have a day job where I build graphs with
a giant team. Um, and we build stuff for
scholarship and research. But we're
going to go and do introductions down
the line here and then we're going to
get into discussion. But I've been in
some other sessions already today. I
hope you've all had some caffeine or
some tea or whatever it is that you need
to perk up because I hope we all have
some discussion with the rest of the
group. Okay, so Anthony, you're up next.
And I want to start. Yeah. [laughter]
Okay. I got the impression that I am in
front of a grand jury. So [laughter]
I will try to be nice.
>> No tomatoes to be thrown. It's okay.
>> Do not bite. Um so myself, so I am
Anthony. So I work at AWS. Um I am a
senior IML strategist and business
development guy. Um so what I do, my
team cover and spot the best funer
around here in Europe. um and we we help
them grow. So I am also in relationship
with VCs. So this is my main role. But
alongside that uh I like to do some kind
of thought leadership around uh graph
and generative AI. My belief is that the
best way to build GI products is to
combine it with graph technologies. So
this is a a strong belief that I have
that is more and more backed by data.
Before that I worked as a I civil
servant in France uh in the social
security system where where I push for
IML project there and uh in in startup
and large corporation like L'Oreal. So
yeah that's my uh
Leah. Yeah.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Uh I'm Leah
Miller. I'm a lead ontologist at SNP
Global and um my background is in uh
philosophy and sociology originally and
I've been uh a knowledge engineer and a
data architect and an ontologist and I
am uh my involvement in the AI space
right now is uh working with developers
on uh creating knowledge graphs for
graph rag or text to query.
And so I'm kind of on the uh use case
end and trying to get it to work with uh
enterprise data which is a really
exciting and uh experimental uh thing
happening now.
>> Peter, you can go next.
>> Sure.
>> Hi everyone. Um so my name is Peter
Crocker. I'm chief exec at Oxford
Semantic Technologies. Um
uh chief exec but joined as CTO. So
please don't uh pigeon hole me as just
the business guy. Um uh passion for
technology from a from a very early age
since since I was first introduced to
Lego I think. Um background I started my
working life I guess as a mainframe
programmer for for IBM. Spent many years
in enterprise IT consulting
um architect
and the lot. um and then was approached
uh to come and uh go back to back to my
roots, go back to Oxford where I was
born and and studied um to look at this
small startup that was being spun out of
the university. Um from there we built
our company Oxford Sm Technologies. Um
our core technology comes out of that
research RDF Fox and it's been a
pleasure privilege um to to work with a
fantastic team of very talented people
to to build that company uh and take it
from
well just a handful of people in an idea
some code to a company that recently was
acquired by Samsung and put at the heart
of their AI strategy. So pleasure to be
with you today.
>> If you needed any more uh evidence that
knowledge graph and AI go together
>> right there. I've literally sent that to
tons of people just to say that exact
phrase.
>> Yeah, we had a sorry
>> no
>> we you will get your introduction. Yeah,
we we recently recently I think we had a
article in Forbes where you know graph
was the center of attention. Um, I think
you're you'll be seeing a lot more.
>> Yeah, that's the one I sent around. I
said the thing I just said, guys, if you
if you've had doubts, here you go. Okay.
[laughter]
>> Uh, hi everyone. I'm Tony Seal, the
knowledge graph guy. So, I've been
working with uh knowledge graphs now
primarily in investment banks uh sort of
for the last uh 10 years. So, rubber
meets the road in terms of trying to
apply the technology in these highly
regulated high stakes uh environments.
[clears throat] initially uh doing the
machine learning side with uh GNN's so
like uh graph-based neural networks but
then obviously uh two two three years
ago the out came the large language
models and so recently I've just been
focused on the connection of those two
technologies uh together and seeing how
you get the best out of both of those.
>> Very nice. And if you haven't caught on,
we have a powerhouse of experience up
here and honestly in the audience as
well. So this is going to be exciting.
So let's go ahead and kick it off. And
the the big question, why are people
talking about AI and graphs together so
much from your experience, from your
perspective? And you have the mic
already, so why don't you start?
>> Yeah, I would I would break that down
into two parts probably. So, so, so one
part is the uh data side which for
anybody that was listening to my uh
keynote uh yesterday I you know I think
I I pretty elaborately went into that
that essentially you can't do AI without
data and therefore for any organization
their primary AI strategy before
anything else is to get their data
strategy right. So just organize your
data because at the moment most
organizations it's like a kind of dirty
secret um that in a large organization
their data is in disarray at the moment
and and I kind of coming from the
finance I see it like the credit default
swap crisis that we had with the credit
crunch where it was like kind of a few
people were kind of looking around
saying do you know what these mortgage
back securities they they don't actually
add up like there's this bad mortgage in
here and you know Anybody that's been
inside a large enterprise, if they think
about it, kind of knows this the data
estate does not add up at the moment.
It's not well organized. It's not well
connected. So that's on one level. And
then I think the other level, which is
kind of going to be the more interesting
one to go into, I think I'm hoping we're
going to go into on the panel today, is
more kind of on then on the other side
of like, well, generative models, you
know, they're they're they're great that
they're awesome. Uh they've got this
kind of creative uh ability. They can
write poetry. They can do all this sort
of stuff. But in a again in in in a in
any kind of complex situation or
regulated environment, I don't want you
writing poetry. I want you you know
executing this particular business case
and doing it with accuracy all uh right
all of the time. So then the question
kind of comes well how do you put
control around one of these models? And
we can kind of we can we can go into it
and I won't talk about it and take too
long now. But I think there's a there's
a strong hypothesis uh that that that
that be keen to explore that graphs are
the way of most effectively putting
control in to the uh generative models
and and I think it's it's it's probably
this latter one that is the major reason
why it's hyping up so much now.
>> Absolutely. And you know accuracy for
your use case and your company, right? I
mean, I know you you know that, of
course, but you know, for the audience
that isn't maybe as familiar with these
things. That's the thing that AI doesn't
really understand. It's a general model.
It knows a whole lot about, you know,
who Nicki Minaj is, but that's not
really helpful for my um banking use
case, unless, you know, we're trying to
insure her, which I don't know if I
would do. Anyways, if anyone knows who
Nicki Minaj is. Uh Peter, it looks like
you're up next.
>> Yeah. So, just to really carry on and
try not to repeat um what T was saying,
accuracy, explanability, these are all
characteristics we need when we're
dealing with, you know, real people,
their their data and real businesses and
their data. I I guess I'd add sort of
helping scale the expert knowledge
that's intrinsic or actually
differentiate differentiates you as a
business or an organization. Um and and
for that it's graphs are a fantastic way
to organize your data. Um graphs are
also an excellent place on which to
perform logic on top of your data. So
we'll talking a fair amount about
reasoning and and that really for me is
the application of logic on top of on
top of your data to expand it to to to
something that's useful and and yeah in
terms of the connection back to to
generative AI you know they are they are
very much complimentary but one will
make stuff up one will get you accurate
answers let's let's let's build the
poetry if you like to use your analogy
let's build the poetry on on top of
facts and accuracy and something that is
explainable um and um and uh and going
to compute things accurately for you.
Thank you. Um
I will try to to not repeat what has
been said. Um I think so we will have a
second phase in genai that is agentic
systems. So we are talking more and more
about this. Um a lot of investments are
going into these kind of startups. So
agentic is like using genai to automate
processes uh make decision adapt to
context and my belief but I see more and
more papers more and more product that
are doing this is that by using
knowledge graph craft technologies it
allow these agentic system to perform
much more better more accurate more
interpretable
uh you can have a reasoning layer on the
graph also
Uh let me take an example on memory
systems. Um so lots of those agents
wants to have a memory of what has been
happening with the user. The best way to
build this memory system is this graph.
Um if you vectorized because one
alternative could be to use only a
vector database. Um if you only
vectorize those memories, you can't
reason on it. Okay? you will only
perform semantic similarities on those
memories uh and the accuracy would be
bad and the more memories you will have
the more memory system will scale and
the more the accuracy will drop. Okay.
So by by organizing your data in a graph
system by adding um
my colleague from semantic I explained
logic um logic inference on this data
you can have much more accurate aent
agentic system. Yeah. So this is um I
think uh this neuros symbolic approach
is the best approach we have right now
in AI to to tackle the challenges that
uh we want to to to deal with here.
>> Yeah. So [clears throat] plus one to
what everyone has said. Um I think uh
from the um the enterprise data side I'm
really excited to see that uh graphs are
becoming uh more and more um uh
prevalent as a solution for the for our
AI uh solutions and adding adding that
to our to our pipelines. Uh so there's
just more demand for uh okay what is a
knowledge graph? how do I uh convert my
data into a knowledge graph or how do I
uh leverage ontologies to add in
metadata about my data? And I think it's
um uh you know we're we're on the end of
you know using all the the the different
methods and tools and and testing it out
and seeing uh seeing what works. And
it's it's very much um I know that it's
extremely important to have graphs.
I've, you know, we all know that we're
all here and I think it's just becoming
uh more and more known that that's just
something that we're going to need to to
leverage uh when it comes to accuracy
and representing our data accurately. Um
yeah.
>> So, one thing that you have all
mentioned is accuracy.
How many of us agree on everything all
the time? We're all experts or experts
in something.
It doesn't always happen. And in fact,
there was someone earlier today that was
talking about this is that is if you ask
a room full of lawyers how this one
thing is, what is the fact, they will
all disagree. So, how do you deal with
disagreements in your data which might
actually be valid?
>> Whoever wants to go first.
>> Yeah,
>> I caught them with a new question.
Sorry.
Maybe I won't not give a direct answer
but um introduce this team because I
think evaluation
um so when I talk to startups when a
startup told me I ask one question do
you have an evaluation system of your
solution
uh and if it if they don't have think
about it I think it's a it's a big
mistake okay because AI system are
evolving systems uh they will
continuously be improved and you need to
be able to measure what is happening and
to improve it. Okay, it's a basics
principle of machine learning operation.
Okay, classical machine learning for
geni is the same thing. the stack to
evaluate it is emerging. Okay. Um I will
give you for example a startup that is
successful in this is for example. So
I'm not biased but it's a French
startup. Okay. In French but but but
yeah they I think they are doing great.
Um yeah but on your question um
depending on the task you are dealing
with
that can be case where you have one
correct answer if you take healthcare
um
depending on the state-of-the-art of the
scientific comm knowledge okay there is
one answer to this disease
so you have I mean an agreement of
experts on on this and so on. Okay. For
more creative task
like writing
a new way to sales to sell a product,
there is no correct answer. Okay. Um but
the more the contextual knowledge model
will be will have the more it will
explore path. Okay. For creative you you
you want to the product to to explore
different option and for the user to
choose. Okay. So I I think we need to
think about the nature of the task.
Yeah. And of course you need to have a
collect that evaluation data and and
evaluate uh your output based on this
benchmark etc. And more and more what we
are seeing is the emergence of LLM as
judge.
Okay. And I will end here.
I think for the current state the
scientific uh thinking about LLM as
judge is very early. Um and there might
be uh an opportunity to use a graph also
to evaluate because what you want to do
when you do evaluation you want
consistency.
uh you want to remember what has been
evaluated before and maybe there is
opportunity here to build a graph uh
agentic graph evaluation system uh to
have this kind of consistency
memory of what has been evaluated etc
start to create yeah so this is my
thinking
I think your question is taking us in
philosophy and um you remind me of a
conversation dinner table my my daughter
was studied philosophy Um and you know I
was talking about truth and she said
well what is truth right? Um so so yes
truth truth is um can be can be
subjective truth does evolve over time
um but as
I guess as a business as an organization
you you are taking a position right you
are taking a position to say this is
what I understand truth to be this is
how I'm maybe representing you in a
legal position and I am going to stick
to this truth or in a medical context
you don't go to your doctor and expect
them to come back with well actually the
the research search is divided and
there's 10 different things but I'm
going to pres prescribe you you know
this one thing so businesses do take a
position businesses are are there to
differentiate themselves from other
businesses to take a position on what
they believe truth to be um and uh and I
think from there we can we can progress
you can
>> sounds like there's a theme there too to
make sure the information is presented
so that the end user can make a decision
it's informed
>> if if that's appropriate for your use
case yes or if as a business you want to
you know you are you are taken position
which you think is the best
>> truth to follow then you know both but I
I think you know and ultimately we can
all say well we could we could model
alternative truths but but mostly we
find businesses you know want to take a
position want to mark their position as
this is where I think I'm going to add
value to you as a customer and um yes
other truths exist go by
>> ultimately it's about the accuracy of
the the LLM that it's supporting right
Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, so I think to answer this
question, it gets to the heart of things
in a way. So, the best the best thing to
do is to to to zoom out a little bit and
look at the relationship between the
large language model and the graph. So,
okay, we're kind of making it a bit of
an assumption that the graph is the best
way of of of doing this, which maybe we
can we can talk about, but let's let's
forget that for a second and just say
[clears throat] you can divide the world
into like natural systems and formal
systems. So, an example of a formal
system would be mathematics. Okay, it's
it's it's it's a perfectly good formal
system. Um, an ontology is another
example of a uh formal system. Um and
and you can think of any number of uh
Java is a programming language with a
compiler is a formal system and then we
have natural systems. So natural systems
exist in the biological world and they
they represent reality. They're the and
and the nature of these two different
systems are quite are quite distinct
because uh natural systems are existing
in this kind of continuous world. you
can kind of see it almost like a a
river, you know, it's like everything's
flowing into everything else. There's
not there's not one thing that's
discreet. And and actually when you
think of large language models in many
ways, although that we kind of like go
around between these natural and formal
systems and large language models are
obviously based on peace-wise linear
algebra at the end of the day, which but
when you kind of put them all together
into one of these very big models with
all of this kind of nonlinearity going
on in there, the large language model is
more like is is better considered like a
natural system in that context really.
So it's probi it's probabilistic it's
huristic it's continuous
um it has this uh creativity that the
other the flip side of which is
hallucination
and it's not computable so you can't
compute over uh that and and you can't
look inside it um because it's a black
box inside it you know with people are
trying and there is stuff that you can
do to like break down back to that kind
of peace-wise linear algebra stuff to to
to do stuff there but you but but
fundamentally it isn't. And and and so
you can think of that as like
simulation. It's like it's it's it's a
simulation of the world. And then what
like an ontology or a graph is and I
think this kind of comes into why graphs
are particularly good at this is graphs
are a discrete uh representation of
that. So like like at a mathematical
level then when we're putting stuff into
graphs they tend to be the discrete
versions of uh continuous calculations.
So um you've got separate nodes and
you've got separate edges and I can
compute and I can do things like logical
deductive closure on there. And then
when you when you so apologies for the
kind of the the the background to that
but then if if we kind of take that lens
between seeing these kind of two
different parts like the natural system
and the formal formalized system and
then we kind of think of that question
of ambiguity. All right. So in both
sense they're a form of knowledge
capture and a form of intelligence and
quite a good way of understanding
intelligence is the ability to abstract
like can you uh abstract the pertinent
details and and bring up the level of
abstraction and within like ontology
design that's exactly what we're doing.
We you know we're creating these like
kind of abstractions uh and and we're
taking a position we're doing we're not
doing simula simulation we're doing
modeling. So, and as as as Peter was
saying like at in a company at the end
of the day, you need to take a position.
You you you are nailing your onlogical
colors to the mast at that point. Yeah.
Yeah. You you you this is what we think
and this is what differentiates us. And
I in in that sense
um I think that you can think of the
situations where you have ambiguity then
you have we have two techniques uh for
handling that within or or or so all
right ambiguity within the large
language model that's handled just kind
of because it's a natural system it
naturally handles ambiguity. So one
concept flows into another concept. It's
a on a continuous it's that it's that
watery kind of uh metaphor. I can just
and you you can see it with the large
with with with the with the image uh
models they they'll just morph one image
into another on this continuous uh
space. You know a cat can turn into a
dog and you'll see on this continuous
spectrum as it moves from one to the
other. On our graph side it doesn't work
like that because I have a separate
category and I have a for dog and I have
a separate category for cat but they're
both mammals. So I can model that within
that kind of formal uh uh abstraction
that I can put into the ontology. The
other thing that we can do is then put
context in. So again like the on on the
large language model the context is kind
of naturally flowing from one thing into
the next smeared across this embedding
vector space. But within a graph in the
discrete space I can have edges linking
into these different things. And that
will allow me to look at the context.
And it's with these two mechanisms that
ambiguity
uh can be handled on the discrete side
which is context on one side by by
putting edges in and knowing what the
kind of local neighborhood is within the
graph and then abstraction on the
ontology side by being able to create
the formal modeling. But the really cool
thing, the really cool thing is that now
that we're not limited just to that to
to to doing that because we've got the
large language model and because we have
these two systems, you can create this
like neural symbolic loop and that's
where the real power comes because now
we're like iterating between these
different spaces. We're going into the
natural world and we're using the power
of the large language model to explore a
space in continuous world and then we're
saying well within the context of this
organization having explored the world
I'm now going to extract a formal model
from that which is like a kind of piece
of knowledge which I believe to be
useful and I'm going to actually kind of
represent in this discrete way and now
I'm going to persist that down into the
graph or I'm going to persist that into
the ontology and then that'll be
available for me to use later on. Sorry
for kind of going on there. That's
that's a really good explanation. I'm
glad you went through that because I
mean in my experience, you know, dealing
with things like this, it's when you see
something that has it's a disputed
thing. So, a good example, there's a lot
of uh academic research that says
vitamin C can help with cancer patients,
and there's a tiny subset that says it
actually hurts. And it's like, well,
wait a minute, those are completely
opposite. One has a ton of ev evidence,
one does not have as much. But wow,
that's really dangerous. So we need to
understand that for specific use cases.
So what I found when doing some
investigation into this is that that it
was really an outlier. It was and if you
are on this specific cancer drug, it is
not good for you. That was the critical
piece. So normally when I see this in
real life when looking at at things in
the graph in the AI space, those
disputes actually just mean there's more
context that's needed for the model to
understand it more appropriately and
then you put that into your graph and
then it understands it every single time
which is lovely. Um and we've seen a lot
of people claiming and this is where
we're going to get into the next
question and let's do Leah do you want
to respond to the question that we just
went through? I want no. Okay. Okay.
We'll go we'll go on then. Um, but a lot
of people are claiming that, you know,
with a knowledge graph, you can increase
the accuracy of your LM by X percent and
we've seen lots of different
percentages. It depends on the use case
and the data and so on and so forth. But
who's measuring this? How is it being
measured? Do you have thoughts on how
others are measuring it? How you think
that measuring the accuracy can be done?
So this is a question of like uh what
what data do we have on graph rag
actually being more effective than than
than other mechanisms of rank. Yeah,
there there there are a bunch of paper I
had someone on one of my LinkedIn uh
people put it exactly that question and
so I could share uh with this group
afterwards like the papers that I
responded to. Uh
>> yeah, there's a ton of them out there.
That's
>> there. Uh Juan's one from data.orld,
Worldw and Dean's one is is a really
good one that's just like kind of on the
you know the SQL uh benchmark and it's
kind of like a no-brainer that you kind
of putting the semantic layer in and
that's increasing the accuracy. And then
there's a bunch of more academic ones
which tend to go into like the reasoning
path. So you know it's like okay I'm
going to I'm going to show it these kind
of reasoning facts from the knowledge
graph and then uh then they do benchmark
on accuracy.
>> Yeah. At the end of the day we need to
have the data to support this with our
businesses right. So
>> yeah, I guess um just echo plenty plenty
of research in this space. Um but maybe
to to add to that, if you're looking to
convince your business, they may not
want to troll through the the research.
So just to to add to that, um you know,
look look at the announcements of of big
organizations. Um look actually at the
very first announcement I think in the
FT from Microsoft when they talked about
their partnership with OpenAI. Buried
within that text was the word, you know,
semantic technology. Um, you know, it
was was uh it was it was a side note,
but it was clear that that's what
they're building.
>> Change the narrative. Not a side note.
>> Yeah. Um,
look at the analysis that's, you know,
always a bit slow. They're finally
coming out from from the likes of
Gartner, the other analysts. Um, they
generally catch up with the industry
eventually. Um, and look at events like
Samsung acquiring us. I mean that's a
cheap one but um or just think about it
right um do you want to rely on symbolic
predictable explicit links that where
you are to our earlier point you know
taking a position or do you want to rely
on a statistical model and sometimes
that's that's good um but but remember
what that statistical model's trained on
um if you've got the budget of open
maybe you could train it on your
business maybe you could nudge a model
into your direction but it's it's
trained on the internet or or a
collection of articles from um it's it's
the average intelligence of the internet
rather than
the accurate or or the position your
business wishes to take. Um and I think
just just thinking about it from that
point of view I I know which one I would
bet my business on
>> on the accuracies. Um one one study that
I like study data world is really good
on text to SQL. So it shows that using
graph technology you increase
considerably the accuracy of your text
to text tossql application and there is
a second paper that shows that by using
an ontology on top of that you increase
it even more
>> [snorts]
>> um but recently there has been a study
by
so
and they showed pretty scientifically I
mean the data is pretty um clear there
is 30% accuracy gap between vector a
good vector databased approach and and
graph rag. Um and what is interesting is
on the they classified the different
types of question. So you have for
example multihop questions where you
need to um to fetch multiple facts to
answer answer the particular question.
Here uh it is twice as accurate than
vector database. Um
for example if you have a temporal
reasoning the I know there's a colleague
here is working on that you you by
representing temporality on the graph of
course will help the LLM sub better this
question you can't do that with vector
database so um what I like about graph
is that it's a reasoning layer by itself
uh so you will have you will two
reasoning layer. You will have the um
fuzzy uh semantic
the the [snorts] predictive next token
one and the symbolic one. But that can
be also predictive. I I mean on on on
graph you can do leak prediction, you
can do uh clustering, you can do
centrality analysis, you can do multiple
analysis on the graph that will help the
reasoning and and what is emerging um
because I I follow also our collect from
Stanford um they are building graph
foundational models okay uh Google has
been doing is doing this also uh it's
called
and there are two models currently where
you so it's a functional graph model
they can understand any types of graph
and perform prediction uh
graph task on it uh without any training
okay so what a prediction that an
hypothesis by using the term of
of Tony that he has been using I I think
this kind of technology will become more
and more complimentary with a large
language model. Yeah. Uh yeah. So
>> uh so from uh our perspective it's very
very important that we are um
benchmarking uh improvements or uh
properly testing that. And I think what
we're running into so uh for example the
the text to SQL versus text to sparkle
um that's we've seen in research uh that
that is performing better. It's handling
certain types of complex questions
better if you have it in um a graph
format and you're using text to uh
sparkle layer. Um the the caveat there
is when it comes to enterprise data it's
very very very messy. So we're running
into uh if I just make uh improvements
to my existing data just as part of that
AI ready data initiative uh will I see
improvements even without even touching
um this uh text to SQL sorry text to
sparkle experiment will I already make
improvements and I think that's uh uh
that's what I'm curious about and I
think it's really sparking the um AI
ready data uh we need to see our you
know evaluate our tech debt and see how
we can optimize uh our existing
databases
um and how we can improve with proper
annotations and cataloging and other
optimizations even before we get to uh
knowledge graph creation or or that
solution I think is really important to
properly benchmark it. So if I can
improve my database, maybe we're where
we want to be. Um, and right now it's
we're seeing improvements, you know,
with um, you know, adding a graph
structure, but it's it's it's uh,
difficult to make that call without kind
of optimizing on both both sides. Yeah,
>> I can just just pick up on that on the
on the text to sparkle and and that has
I think come through
big big improvements and just in the
last in the last few months really uh
with some of the more uh with more
recent um updates to the uh to the
models. um uh but they yeah they they
still struggle and and you you mentioned
right if you if you've got multiple
leaps that you're asking the um the LLM
or the model to generate for you that
they're you're increasing your chances
of them going into hallucination and and
generating you know generating sparkle
perhaps that that doesn't exist and
that's true for sparkle it's it's true
for for SQL so the maybe the point I'd
add here is
What our customers are then doing is
adding
reasoning steps into the graph to
generate connections that don't
necessarily exist within your source
source data putting shortcuts if you
like into the data performing
aggregations you know something that you
don't see in the benchmarks are some of
the things that well they the LLM can't
do right why benchmark something it
can't do so if I want to aggregate data
if I want to ask questions that span
vast amounts of the data traditional rag
approaches struggle. So they don't
actually bench bother benchmarking those
that stuff, right? Um but with graph and
with reasoning with by adding in rules
to say well give me a count of all the
things connected to here or or shortcut
across the things that match this filter
and give that a new meaning give that a
new meaning in the graph and now expose
that to the LLM as a as a new attribute
of the graph. you've suddenly given it
this this superpower where it doesn't
need to go and make up that extra bit of
sparkle that's going to get it in a
twist. Um it it's there as as far as it
was concerned. It was there in the
source data but no reasoning's brought
that in for you um with with some rules.
>> Well, and some
>> Well, I was just going to do like a
little bit of devil's advocate in the
the kind of
>> we had too much agreement. Yeah, we had
too too too much agreement and just to
kind of like throw into the picture like
the 01 models uh and stuff like that
where you know now we are seeing
reasoning that's being introduced in at
the large language model level. So there
they're using reinforcement learning. Um
and you know OpenAI I just saw they
announced like one of their their kind
of slightly silly thing of all their
releases before Christmas thing but one
of them was well now you can actually
custom train 01's reasoning process on
your own reasoning structure. So you can
you can feed it in examples of what your
reasoning structure would be and then
you're using reinforcement learning
there to custom train it on your
reasoning and then you're applying that
to uh to the to the data problem. So you
know there's I think there is a there is
a legitimate there is more there is I
feel still more work to be done here in
terms of like working out exactly what
role graph is going to play. How big is
that? I mean, I think the the the key
point like some kind of something that's
undisputable is on the rag on the
retrieval side. I think Anthony
something you said in one of your talks
that uh retrieval is reasoning. You
know, you you you are to do smart
retrieval in a dynamic situation uh you
are reasoning. So to a certain extent,
how much do I want to pull down push
down some of that reasoning process into
the retrieval so that I'm getting just
the right context specific information
back and vector search and BM25 we're
only going to go so far there and we
anybody that's done it knows knows that
but yeah I think there's an interesting
question to like well as
as test time as like kind of inference
time test time compute increases as
reasoning models increase with And you
can custom train them. How much do we
need the graph there?
So what is so Tony has evoked the notion
of inference scaling that is to say you
make more compute as a reasoning time on
the LM. um the problem so it's an
approach that will be more and more
explored but it I think it's
complimentary with graph rag and it
won't be used for all reasoning task uh
because it it cost more okay um it's not
efficient um
the way openai is selling it is for
scientific mathematical
uh scientific Iand task
Okay. So, I think it will be used for
really specific uh high value task that
you don't really need in 90
60% of current Excel task in business
operation. Yeah. So, yeah, I think it
will have a place in the stack but not
as as much as Yeah. for the the
reasoning. Yeah. I think reasoning is
retrieval. Why? So there is a a
beautiful paper that has been released
uh last week that is called a agentless.
They show that you don't need a
sophisticated uh agentic system to do
coding.
you you just only need to give the LLM
or the agent the proper parts of the
codebase to help the coder perform its
coding operation. So agent for code is
more a problem of what to retrieve from
the codebase to perform the task than it
is to have a sophisticated LLM that has
been uh that has were 100% on code
benchmark etc. Okay. Why? Because in
codebase you have dependencies.
Uh
yeah, you need to retrieve the proper
part in the code to to to for the agent
to be really helpful. Yeah. So this is
what I Yeah.
Well, one of the things that um comes up
all the time in research that you know
that I'm seeing is there's a lot of
guard rails on the the vanilla models
before you use any uh anything that
we're talking about with with a
knowledge graph. And that's a good
thing, right? Um guardrails are good
except when it's so vanilla that it's
almost useless. And that's where a
knowledge graph also helps where it can
add back in some of that specificity
that otherwise would have been taken out
because the AI doesn't want to get it
wrong. It is to trained I don't want to
get it wrong. So I'm going to go super
vague here. And I look at it as a
research and say that is totally useless
for me. Thank you. Um so having the
graph there to help supplant that is
also very helpful as far as the the
reasoning goes. But we're talking about
rag a little bit. Where does rag fit
into all of this? Do you need to use
rag? Can you use your graph for other
things in the AI space without having to
go into the rag direction? What's what's
that look like for you?
>> Okay.
>> I don't want to stump anyone.
>> You want um
what I I like.
So
I am uh I'm writing I want I want I
don't want to do marketing I'm writing
something on agentic okay in agent rag
is only one component okay um so you
have a tool management memory management
like I told okay you have all of these
components to make the agent work um
what I like for example is to use the
graph database to integrate also
predictive modeling
uh classical machine learning for
example within it uh it's not only rag
is to use a graph as a reasoning engine
um I like it I mean um uh graph has been
used for recommendation they have been
used for uh fraud detection they have
been used they have many usage that you
can that you can uh recycle or even um
integrate into an agentic pipeline.
Okay. And I think I think we will more
and more see this because what is coming
with aentic is that
it's a bold prediction but it has
already been made.
The future of interaction between
computer the future interaction with
computer will be more and more be done
by agents.
You will have less and less interaction
between human and computer. You will
have an intermediary
that will do the task for us. Okay, I
will give you an example. I won't sell
their product but perplexity they are
integrating shopping agent. Okay, that
shop for us. Okay, you will have um
Slack agents that read all your messages
and give you maybe a sum up or answer
for you. Myself, I have integrated
don't take it bad but LinkedIn agent
okay that can answer your DM or analyze
it. uh prioritize them etc etc. So you
will have more and more of those
intermediaries into the stack. So and
for those to work properly I think you
will need some kind of persistent memory
and and gra graph technologies is for
it's for sure I think it's the best data
model the best data modeling approach
that we have comes from the graph space
it's my thinking. Oh yeah,
>> I can speak.
>> Yeah, I' I'd echo that. I think it comes
back to that conceptualization of like
the uh formal and natural systems. So
the agents is are where we're going and
therefore I believe that you going to
need at least some kind of formal
representation for all tasks. So that's
planning within the agent as well, you
know. So we've had kind of like we
started out with like plain prompts then
we kind of went graph of thought and now
we're currently on this kind of tree of
thought and tree search but for anybody
who's done ETL you know we use we use
DAGs for any kind of workflow because
within a graph structure you know even
just like a direct a directed as cyclic
graph you can do branch and join
operations which you can't do in a tree.
So you know I could have parallel plans
that are going off that are exploring
different avenues of the thought process
that I then converge down into one node
which I can do with a directed cyclic
graph that I you can't do that with a
tree because you you can just think of a
tree structure they can't branch and
join. That's just like one example and
that's before you get out of where I
think my personal view which is when I
like project like way out into the
future is [clears throat]
the real power is actually in kind of
some of this nonlinear stuff. So like
you go beyond gra DAGs which are
directed as cyclic graphs which don't
have cycles in them. Actually the real
magic is is often in the cycles
themselves. So we we're not we're not
there yet. But you know that's I think
once we kind of get to that point that
you're actually kind of working some of
these like non these nonlinearities that
the graph structure can handle and then
it's it's it's all just also just like a
question of like break it down to like
the mathematics of like what is the most
when you know in maths when you want a
data structure that is the most flexible
discrete data structure what is it? it's
a graph and you know that's you know
anything else is not as expressive as
that. So we want the most expressive
data structure you know okay like hyper
graphs and all this stuff that that I
don't fully you know get [laughter]
the getting get into uh you know maybe
down the line too. Well, it's
interesting too. The the the train has
left the station. They are called
agents. But in my mind, anytime I
describe this to non-technical folks, I
always say, hey, uh you know what a grad
student does. That's what this is,
right? It's not to your point, it's not
just give a task, go because you don't
necessarily need this very sophisticated
system to to do that as a you know, like
a travel agent. You say, I'm going to
this place, go find me the best route
there. It's more like a grad student or
having lots of grad students, which is
nice where you give they're very
talented, but they're not quite there.
They're not experts, but you can give
them lots of tasks, but they come back
to you and say, "Is this right? No, no,
no, that's not right." And then you
correct them. So, it's this cyclical way
of of adding in that that knowledge to
make it better and better.
>> Yeah. And I think you know there's a big
part here where you um
generative systems can can add content
to the graph as well, right? Um but
again, you want you do want to apply
some constraints to that or at least
tell tell the system this is what's
going to be useful. This is what I'd
actually like you to capture because
coming back to our earlier points, this
is the position I'm taking and this is
the value I'm trying to offer to my
customers. So here is the
here is the schema if you like. Here is
the here's the logic I'd like you to
capture from this piece of text or this
this user's email or interaction or or
so on. But I'd like to capture I'd like
you to capture it in this way because
this is how I think about my my business
or the value that I'm prop you know
proposing to my to my customers. So
there's there's a piece where you know
agents can can help you
organize what a you know we would call
thoughts but organize our organize our
data in a way that we think is going to
mean we we project the best value into
into society. Um
>> no you go first.
>> Okay. Are you sure?
Um so yeah I wanted to uh so back to the
the question around um not always using
rag or using agents um I think uh so
back to not necessarily at S&P but uh
the Amazon days uh voice assistants
Alexa uh this was you know pre uh LLM
explosion uh it's normal to have uh
several um response systems and you have
that planning there. That's that's kind
of uh not a new concept at all to have
different sources. Uh you're going to um
ping your knowledge graph for for an
answer particular kind of question.
You're going to get your statistical
layer to respond. So I think that's uh
that seems like the the the way to go.
So it's not um you know an overemphasis
on uh graph rag or graphs in particular
to respond to everything. Uh and I also
wanted to point out I'm noticing that uh
some things that an LLM uh can handle uh
some you know standard uh NLP techniques
can also handle and so the you know the
lazy graph rag is is doing just that you
know kind of we don't need to use an LLM
at this point. Let's go back to this
triedand-true uh step for you know cost
and efficiency. So I uh yeah don't want
to overemphasize on all the expensive
bits but kind of you know being more uh
strategic with
>> that's part of being responsible AI
right is try the other
other solutions that might be just as
good but more responsible from
environment and cost and and you know
social responsibility and all those
things
>> my my belief is that in production
because what allow this kind of
technology of having an LLM or SLM and
graph
is to continuously improve it because
you continuously improve the knowledge
base. Uh you would continuously improve
also the LLM because you can fine-tune
it or or even distill it and find a
smaller ones that perform as good. this
morning has been released and I do talk
about competition a paper by Microsoft
about the new FI model that perform as
good as a 70B model uh in small model.
uh okay uh we will I think I think see
uh a movement to efficiency small model
etc and graph allow this because um
graph uh so we can optimize also the
query on the graphics but allow graph is
a isn't is an evolving system is not a
fixed system it can be improved you when
you analyze
inaccuracy you can go back to the graph
maybe to improve it. Uh my colleague
speak about feature engineering on the
graph also. You can we go back to the
old days of ML where you perform
features engineering on your data set.
It's the same thing with a graph. So I
think it will be a an essential
companion of genai application okay for
a long time u because uh I don't think
um we will see uh any major breakthrough
in AI uh that is as effective as the LLM
in the coming month I mean okay let me
make a bold prediction but I don't see
this coming this soon okay new types of
model But even then when you think about
it every model needs data and needs
training its training is fixed. Okay. Uh
when you train a model is has been
trained on certain data. Uh it has been
trained on the past. Okay. Uh so
we don't have uh we only can create
better reasoning agent reasoning uh
models. Okay. uh but they need to reason
on something. Okay. Uh even the best
reasoning uh model if it don't have
access to the data of the company it
will create no value at all. Okay. And
the best way to reason on the data of
the company is to model it as a graph
system. It's uh for me it's evident.
Yeah. I think um thing that's just come
out in the recent comments is um yeah e
efficiency you know doing using the
right tool for the for the job right and
for us that recent recent times that
that's focused when you're trying to put
all of this technology on on these
things right on on these devices because
ultimately your your your battery will
uh your battery life will be dependent
on where you're where you're performing
the where you're performing the task and
if you are performing logical reasoning
it doesn't make sense to put that in
in the LLM and throw seven billion or
however many parameters in a neural
network to go and compute some some
piece of logic the right task for the
right right job. So
>> so we are nearing time so I want to
before we get into closing remarks I
want to ask the audience if there are
any questions for our lovely panelists.
>> Um it's for Anthony. uh you mentioned
that Google are foraying into like
building knowledge graphs or
foundational models that you said that
run off knowledge graphs.
>> Is it just a matter of time before open
AI and anthropic follow suit?
>> No no um so they are doing a beautiful
research on this. It's called the talk
to any graph or I don't remember the the
name of the paper but but they have two
it's open source even you can um
we are experiment experimenting in my my
in my my intellectual work on this on
yeah you have a foundational graph
models that are emerging it's a trend uh
um they are not
with the spread right now but yeah it's
a so it's model that can understand that
has been trained to understand any types
of it does in context learning on the
graph. The the main advantages of LLM is
that they can understand any context.
Okay, they perform in context learning.
Okay, it's the main value of LM today.
Okay, it can learn on the task that you
give it as example.
Those um foundational graph model will
do the same. They will learn on the
graph that they have been provided. The
problem right now with graph technology
is that you need to train your GNN you
need to train your algorithm. Okay. To
have this kind of graph national model
they can perfectly understand
uh what what the graph is about. Okay.
Um and their research for example has
been at first to transform to translate
the graph as something that can be
understood by an LLM. Okay. and they are
moving for I mean alongside that they
they are creating also yes graph for
national model but it's also Stanford
thing uh Stanford is working on on this
also yeah I think they're two they're
two separate efforts I think at the
moment but they're bringing them
together so like the foundation the
graph foundational is that they've uh
they they've taken like the neural
bellman Ford stuff uh and which is like
path-based
learning and then they've trained that
on every known knowledge graph and then
what turns out is that the patterns that
exist within that at the kind of
categorical level they apply across all
graphs so like the foundational models
do and then the the talk to your graph
thing what they're doing is in the final
layer of the neural network they're um
[clears throat] putting some waitings in
they just kind of append like some uh uh
um waitings in on the vector which are
like graph specific. Uh so then you can
you basically train up those particular
parameters so that it can then handle
graph tasks uh more efficiently like you
know finding shortest path finding
centrality.
>> So that's one good point though you
mentioned all known graphs so most if
not all LLMs that are the most popular
right now trained on the open web.
There's tons of link data graphs that
are already on the open web. So they
didn't train it specifically on those
knowledge graphs and treat them as
knowledge graphs, but they're in there,
right? I mean, that's why you can get
anything wiki out of it.
>> Yeah. Not we were having this discussion
actually earlier before. Not as much as
like I had originally assumed. So
originally I thought, ah, they're going
to be scraping all of that link data
that's on the web and then they're going
to be using that as part of the training
process. But um and initial
experimentation seemed to bear that out,
but actually I don't think I don't think
so much. Yeah,
>> it's very messy
>> and and I guess approach with caution
because that's not always helpful
because it can mean they they
hallucinate in areas where they have
seen structure out on the web that isn't
representative in the [snorts] in the
ontology or the schema that you're then
providing it. So, you know, you might
occasionally want to play tricks and
say, "Okay, actually, I'm going to
present to you this ontology or this
schema, and I've renamed things so that
you don't get confused by that that
stuff you've been trained out and are
going to, I know, going to hallucinate
on. So, be be warned." Yeah.
>> Thank you. Hey everyone. Um, my name is
Nia Nia Mlin and I'm from Neoforj. So, a
big fan of everyone here, especially the
the wonderful Ashley. Um, so my question
is, uh, what are some, uh, books or
white papers or even people that you all
look up to who are doing either cutting
edge research specifically or just in
general that folk can continue to dive
in and learn from um, about these
specific topics?
One scientist I am fond of is um
Marcus G. Buller is from MIT and he's um
working on um aentic graph system that I
call it for scientific discoveries and
recently he has released a paper where
um he used um kandis kandiski um
painting to find new material new
material design here. So he's mixing
different field to perform scientific
discovery and I mean um they are not
only publishing paper but they are also
releasing um GitHub open source GitHub
you can reproduce what it has been doing
it's very inspiring in term of I would
say reasoning uh implementation
yeah it's really his talk also are
really he publish a lot on on LinkedIn
for each each of his research. Yeah.
>> Um so there's uh so much out there. Uh
um I uh there's a few um GitHub
repositories where they put they kind of
a combination of papers. Uh I signed up
for hugging face uh uh the daily um
updates. I think it's um I try to take
uh I you know uh pay attention to any of
the um major companies that are you know
building these models what the latest
they have on it I think is um always
good to uh or I guess easy to to keep on
top of. Uh but it's uh it's quite
overwhelming to be honest on what to
follow. And there's going to be a paper
out tomorrow that'll completely change
something I'm doing. So that's it.
Um yeah so so for me I'm kind of a
hands-on sort of person so I prefer to
go and find the the notebooks that
people are providing find the popular
ones of those GitHub um
lots of people lots of community folks
already mentioned hugging face lang
chain plenty out there but for for me
it's uh try it and see see what's
actually working
>> my problem is I can never remember
people's uh names.
Um you've obviously got uh you've got
the people on the the papers that so
there's a is it Brian Pres or something
who's the guy at Google who did the talk
to your graph stuff. He's definitely
worth listening to and having a chat to.
Then Michael Grainen is it or something?
I can never pronounce this the surnames.
He's he's now gone to Google as well
actually, but before that he was with
Nvidia and he's doing a lot of the stuff
with the kind of that that graph
foundational stuff. And then Peter uh
what's his name? Uh who who was doing
you know who's done all of the GNN stuff
and has done the uh category theory uh
stuff. And then weirdly I' I'd kind of
recommend like to get your head around
if you want to get your head around the
um this kind of idea of formal and
natural systems which was would kind of
give you the background to like where
this thing is on the bigger level. Um
I'd actually go read an old book by a
mathematical biologist called uh Robert
Rosen and it's called uh what is what is
it? What is it called? Uh life itself.
And he uses uh he takes a categorical so
like category theory which is kind of
like our graphy stuff but in maths and
he takes a category theory view uh of
biological uh systems.
>> Um hi everyone uh my name is Labanu uh
from Oracle. Um I really appreciate
being in the session. I've quite learned
a lot. I really appreciate I just had
two questions but I'm just going to
combine them as one. So with regards to
LLMs you mentioned about guards uh just
very keen to just check so because we
have like a lot of LLMs out there and
most of them still uh you know with
enterprises uh data and all that we are
trying to like you know put moderation
onto that. So can we say that uh graph
databases are going to like come and
place guardrails to that um in the sense
that to ensure that we we can be able to
like filter uh bad contents within the
LLMs. Can we can we uh you know ensure
that can can we have or can we say that
the graph graph databases are going to
like you know make the LLMs more
deterministics in the sense that they
can give the answer as you know without
hallucinating and that and then the
other thing was with regards to security
are are the graph uh you know databases
going to enhance security for the LLMs
thank you
>> I can go given I've got the mic I can go
first on both of those ones so the so
the uh so yes absolutely and that is
this neural symbolic loop. So um
basically what you do is you you use the
large language model to do a bit of
exploration for instance you might point
it at something some textual document
and say extract me out an ontology from
this and then once you've compiled that
ontology down you can pass that into the
context of the large language model to
say do something but here's my formal
specification of what that of
ontologically what that concept is. Then
when it comes back out of the large
language model, you can do this thing
that they call corrective rag, but like
the graph-based version of that, which
is that basically I'll transform the
large language models response back into
a graph and then I'm going to validate
it against you know I could like have a
shackle validation for instance against
the uh against the data that comes out.
So that's on one side. The other and
then on the security side I think the
thing with large language models is
they're very hackable. So you can always
hack them. So the key thing is to
control the data going into them and
that is really about data lineage. So
essentially what you need to do and this
kind of goes into that deep product
deepro thing I was talking about
yesterday. you need to understand all of
the data that is going in to the context
of the LLM that you're feeding it
whether you're fine-tuning it um or you
are uh putting it in in within the
context and you need to make you need to
understand the lineage of where the data
is in a very detailed level uh in order
not to leak things out and and and even
actually again as a conversation we were
having earlier this is going to become
much more subtle as kind of you you've
got to imagine that the generative
models are like suck sucking information
into them. So, so you're going to get
have to people going have to get a lot
more savvy about what information
they're exposing out on the boundary of
their their their their organization
because it's going to be a lot smarter
in terms of the environment that
organizations are in is going to be a
lot smarter in terms of like sucking
signal out of that. You know, you're
inadvertently revealing secrets that you
didn't realize that you were revealing.
Uh yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I think I think you pretty
much answered it in terms of the in
terms of the guardrails you're providing
that by providing a context to say you
know um for this answer here is here is
your context and that context has come
from from from this graph. The the piece
that you can then add is you can make
you can make links to that. So you can
expose to the user here's my here is my
like written answer or
whatever you're choosing to generate. Um
but here's the reference for that and
that reference is now linked and when
logic has been applied to generate some
of that reference material um logical AI
is backing backing some of that context
um you can be explainable about it. So
you can go, you know, one step one step
beyond what generative on its own is
gonna is going to lack which is that
that explanability.
>> I think it's important to also mention
guard rails are there's a lot of
different types of guardrails. So is it
going I think one of the things you
asked was is it going to is graph going
to replace I would say no. I agree with
everything that's being said here but
things like prompt injection a graph is
not going to be the beall endall for
that. So that I just wanted to clarify
that.
Sorry, just I guess just on the security
piece as well. Um, yeah, that that that
that's a challenge, but that's kind of
many aspects to that. So, is this
security of who you're sharing your data
with? Um, is is this security over um
yeah, who who has access to what
information? So all of the classical I
guess um enterprise security questions
exist whenever you're accessing any data
but we also have you know the security
of where are you running your your LLM?
Who's whose services are you relying on
or are you going to bring that inhouse
and protect protect the users in that
way. So there's plenty of aspects to
security that are important to you.
I think the craft won't solve the
security current problem because um it's
a there is a funny competition right now
on the internet. Uh someone has created
an application where you you have to act
the LLM and you can earn money. Uh
recently someone has earned $70,000.
Uh it's a system a payment system where
you have to convince the LLM that he has
to give you money. Uh and you have to
pay to try it. Okay. So it's [snorts]
it's very funny and it has been break
five time I think uh since it has been
put in place. So of course this LLM
system use a lot of guard rails etc to
uh prevent you to hacking it but people
has acted. So I think on the security
layer we will see more and more
innovation. Um, one innovation I think
but maybe I'm mistaken it's on the
structure output on the LM. Uh, there is
a company called takes.
Uh, it's a French one also. I'm biased
[laughter] definitely but they they are
currently outlines. Uh, it's a best
library for structure output. Uh, they
they beat basically everyone. Entropic,
OpenAI, Microsoft
because their structure output is uh uh
more efficient. So 33 times uh the best
library out there for structure output.
Uh and they are more accurate as so it's
100% accurate. Sure. And the outline
library is open source. But um yeah I I
think to make sure the LLM obey to a
certain schema of response for sensitive
application or something like that can
prevent prompt injection or Yeah, I have
been thinking about that with your
question. Yeah. Yeah. I didn't mean to
get us off on a security tangent.
[laughter] I was just not a security
guard rails apply to lots of different
areas,
>> but but graph I think it's not. No, it
won't be enough. Yeah. No,
>> what's it called again?
>> Outlines. Yeah.
>> Yeah, it's currently on GitHub. It's the
most used library for structural output
and there is a real um interconnection
with graph technologies because with the
structure output you can make the LM
respect a certain schema or certain yeah
they have raised 11 million recently and
they have a product that is even better.
So
>> just
>> if you are interested in Yeah.
Yeah. We are really great.
>> You can go to the next.
>> Oh, I was just going to say um time
check. That's all.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, we're we're pretty much out of
time. So I wanted to make sure that we
cognizant of that.
>> But yeah, I want to make sure my two
cents. Yes. Yeah, I don't know if it
fully um covers what you you know are
meaning by uh guardrails completely, but
just uh um I think it's really important
to uh go back to this AI ready data
initiative and um make sure you have a
data catalog that is semantically
enabled is the best way to capture
provenence and lineage and uh think
about annotations that are um coming up.
even I I know that sounds strange, but
getting ahead of uh how we're going to
have to anni annotate bits of the data
in order to um uh make our uh systems
more secure. Um so with data access um
data source um data security even at a
uh document level uh so with our
chunking as well I mean thinking about
it that far ahead of how we're going to
actually annotate uh the data that will
um uh allow us to uh only um pull in
certain parts that are relevant um for
this part of the organization. We we we
don't want to share our data here. It's
very important having those guard rails
is all in the data cataloging annotation
part of it. Uh AI ready data um
initiative that is that uh those
cataloges are backed by graphs usually.
So that's that's where that graph would
come in is in that data cataloging step.
If you're not into AI yet and you're not
into graph yet, invest in your data and
you will be better set. That's my final
thought. Okay. I want to thank our
panelists. Thank you so much. This has
been a lovely conversation.